[Music]
well in addition to love Rihanna might
have Oscar on the brain because the
singer recently said she would love to
win the gold statue one day in fact
she's doing more and more acting next
summer she's starring in ocean's 8 with
Oscar winner Sandra Bullock and Cate
Blanchett and two weeks from today where
are you gonna see RiRi and valerian her
sexiest role yet we need bubble in a
cabaret club called The Gun Club she
right away is an artist she's performing
so here's what we know about RiRi x'
role as a shape-shifting alien named
bubble she's only in one scene which
took six days to shoot and nine months
of special effects work to perfect she's
taking all different types of shapes
back to back to back to back we also
know she morphs into at least five
different looks including a cabaret
singer Cleopatra a Catwoman a sexy nurse
and get this a blob definitely a lot of
changes a lot of makeup changes and a
lot of hair changes the one that took
the longest was probably the Cleopatra
look are you sure you're doing the
movies set in the 28th century was shot
entirely on a soundstage in the suburbs
of Paris and we're told even though
Rihanna arrived with her entourage she
kicked him off the set when it was time
to get to work and she totally earned
the respect of her co-stars Cara
Delevingne and Dane DeHaan who plays the
title role of valerian we got to talk
about Rihanna in this movie
Dane what was it like for you to have a
front-row seat not just to RiRi but this
performance in particular when I would
tell people like what I was going to do
they were really jealous and their jaws
were on the floor it's an iconic bed
this movie for sure it's incredible
[Music]
you